but i think that that's what we love
about you is that you don't get in the
way
and you don't try to like micromanage
you just let us
maybe i take advantage of you maybe
maybe i take a little advantage of you
maybe
i don't look at the there are a lot of
things that you get me you know
like today i go i call i woke up and i
go there's no caffeine
in the [ __ ] building so immediately i
call george and i go
hey dude can you just give me some
[ __ ] that's how i talk
really yeah i always do that yeah man
can you just get me some [ __ ] red
bull man
he goes oh it's already in the fridge
downstairs in the yeah delivered it this
morning bobby i know i know that's what
he says and i go
oh man what a good i wanted it to be
cold for you
yeah i know i know that's why i give you
the [ __ ] compliment man
give me the [ __ ] compliment man yeah
that's you're reliable in that way you
know there's a lot of things that you do
for me
but sometimes when you're too reliable
you be you are forgotten
oh i know that that's yeah but i don't
ever want to i don't want to have to
tell my uh
say what i do or like that's what i like
about you guys is i don't ever have to
like say this is what i've done this is
what i've done this is what i've done
because i trust you guys so i don't have
to i prefer to just be able to be behind
the scenes and do everything
and it takes so much energy to have to
like
also praise myself let's get to the
insults because i'm scared if this
episode doesn't do well
it will hurt my self-esteem it will yeah
this will
no i'm trying to make it so that it's
not it's
give me that worse that's why i'm
actually yeah
that's what i'm saying get to the love
part this guy is getting married like i
want you to give
no we're going to get there we will get
there we're going to get there i just
want to now digest what you just said
right and then i had a specific
feeling that came over me and the old
bobby stepped in
right and i'm just like nah [ __ ] that
okay
yeah go ahead nah [ __ ] that [ __ ] all
that
right it's like you two are very you're
very lucky as well
oh i know you get to work with the best
comics
right on planet earth right and
you know you slid in
right because of your proactive nature
slid in at the right time that's my
favorite word that you say
what nature nature right nature no i
i love it yeah you slid in right and
you're very conniving and opportunistic
that's a just let me this that's what
i'm just saying the old bobby kate came
in
this is not really the new the new
improve we're a team so if i'm
opportunistic it's opportunistic for the
team
boom that's why jordan yeah okay the
baby there's there's strategy and then
there's manipulation
he's all strategy and manipulation no i
think he's all stressed
if i was manipulating you this would be
we would be a lot bigger of a podcast
you would have been on rogan by now
you would have been on or i see
manipulator you know i i'm gonna go on
rogan
i'm tired i will go on rogan
if joe rogan calls me and goes
dude are you available wednesday
which is what he does with everyone else
okay has asked you you were on the list
no no no no
no he has he has to call me i don't know
who to call
to do it right oh i do no but he has to
call me
if he calls me i'll do it he has my
number 100
it's called me before all right so
that's it
do not call them because i don't want
you know you know and also
i don't want you to i don't no because i
don't want you know me
me to go oh can i do it yeah that's true
and this is what the difficulty i work
with is because you refuse to call
and you you refuse to go on any show
that you're not asked onto and you
refuse to ask
a lot of guests because you want them to
ask you and i don't really
wear oh oh really because i'm going to
i'm going to show you my instagram
i too embarrassing i'll show i'll show
you flying faces
i'm going to show you right now you
[ __ ] talked tartared he did louis
okay so i did louis capaldi and then
look at this one all right
louis capaldi ronda rousey i'm going to
read zac braff
i love him hi long shot
can can you do my podcast monday you you
already nagged yourself nothing
long shot yeah nothing okay
i'll show you another one you should
have been like hi zach
not just ronda rousey obviously we know
each other did you say hi
ronda hi rhonda oh you did say hi ronda
bobby lee here
can you do my podcast monday it would
make my heart melt
no response that's a good one all right
yeah my point is that
you seem to think that i don't ask i
asked louis capaldo too
you know and he did not respond so my
point is is that
what else do you want me to do friend i
will ask
okay and i don't like being rejected i
don't like being
i don't like it when people don't and
you know what i do that to a lot of
people
as well but i think that's what george
is saying he's like he's always been
like
let me reach out to them so you don't
get rejected and you're like no no
don't do it no because i also don't want
to make when
you know when people ask me to do
podcasts and a producer reaches out
where it goes to my agent or my manager
it doesn't feel
you know personable personal you know if
you know i've always wanted to do dax
shepard's show
right but i'm not going to ask him to do
it yeah
it's his show he should ask me if he
doesn't want me
and when they don't ask me i think they
don't want me on
yeah right so that's you know it's it's
i'm not you know i'm playing it fair
but i also don't want to get hurt
you know i'm a sensitive guy so you know
if
joe rogan called me and go you know marc
maron you know how i did wtf
he called me five times in a row to do
it
marked it and we scheduled it i went
over to his house and i did it
that's my point friend i want to get to
the love part let's go to the love yeah
we have
we have george here he's getting married
it's a really weird time to get married
um
so i want to know coming from the king
himself what you think
are what advice can you give to a newly
married man
five five five tips on love hot tapes